hi this is dr. Gregory Sadler I'm a
professor of philosophy and the
president and founder of an educational
consulting company called reason IO
where we put philosophy into practice
I've studied and taught philosophy for
over 20 years and I find that many
people run into difficulties reading
classic philosophical texts sometimes
it's the way things are said or how the
text is structured but the concepts
themselves are not always that
complicated and that's where I come in
to help students and lifelong learners
I've been producing longer lecture
videos and posting them to youtube many
viewers say they find them useful what
you're currently watching is part of a
new series of shorter videos each of
them focused on one core concept from an
important philosophical text I hope you
find it useful as well one of the
central preoccupations of decart's work
the meditations on First Philosophy is
discerning what happens when we make
mistakes he wants to ultimately not only
avoid making mistakes when it comes to
not only the true and the false but also
the bad and the good but to understand
the source of errors his hope is to
eventually develop a philosophy that
unlike the other ones up until his time
the way he frames it would be free of
errors so this requires understanding
what happens when we go astray which is
what error means right our honoree is
too to go astray to lose the path the
path to truth the path to what is good
for us so in considering this in
meditation for take heart is going to
start out by telling us what error is to
begin with and he says that early on
it's a kind of deficit a default right a
lack among Kamal in French or more
strictly speaking it's actually not
those just by themselves but rather a
privation
and privation is a metaphysical term
that means the lack of something that
ought to be there that that in that kind
of thing would normally be present so
you know a classic example is of being
blind being blind as a privation for a
human being but it is not for an animal
that lacks eyes right or a plant a plant
isn't blind or sighted right so what is
the privation of that privation what's
lacking is knowledge Coney sauce in
French that should be there in the mind
in the human mind that's what leads us
to go astray to mistake the false for
the true or the bad for the good and
Descartes is going to tell us that it
happens not in a simple way but because
of a concurrence of two and he calls
them causes now neither of these we
should preface is by itself a cause of
error these are two faculties two powers
as he says within the human being the
human mind specifically that of
understanding Anton de Mol right the
part of us that that that not only
conceptualizes but also makes sense of
things and then the will the Volante or
he also uses as a synonym for this liebe
Arbeit right both of them more or less
function in the same way in this work
and so you have to put these two things
together now when you do that you get
something else
that Descartes here you know and he's
not the only philosopher to think about
things this way calls a judgement so
this is a very important point we often
think as if error is something wrong
with somebody's mind there's there's a
little simply lack knowledge about
something that's not enough to be error
or they've got mistaken ideas about
something right idea
that don't correspond to the reality of
things so let's say they for example
think that the reason why everything is
going bad on their farm is because
witches have cursed their farm because
the witches are jealous of their their
productivity right so well there are no
witches and even if there were your farm
isn't really that productive anyway so
you're working on false information for
Descartes that false information isn't
just false because we it doesn't map
onto reality we misunderstand things
it's because on some level we affirm
that to be the case so this is a very
important clarification to make we have
to have this concurrence of two causes
as he says in order to make mistakes so
the understanding is part of this the
untanned amount in French it's the power
of conceiving ideas and the
understanding doesn't actually tell you
whether those ideas are true or false in
the sense of conforming to things say
outside of our mind or even true or
false in the sense of you know being
completely consistent we still need the
the working of the will and this shows
you just how important the will actually
turns out to be in de cartes philosophy
we often talk about him as being a
rationalist and intellectualist and all
that and that's true
he is a rationalist he does think that
the human mind does have some incredible
capacities but it's the will that
actually has greater power than the
intellect as a matter of fact what the
understanding or intellect does is
proposes ideas to the will it says
here's what I got what do you think
about that and we might also roll in as
Descartes mentions our memory and our
Faculty of imagination as well into this
this understanding the current makes a
distinction between imagination and
understanding a little bit later on that
turns out to be important but the point
is
all of our cognitive faculties merely
provide ideas merely produce ideas they
don't actually take a stand on whether
those ideas are true or false what does
that the will the will the Volante or
the bar beat is a capacity or power
pouvoir to choose alia in french to
elect between options to now notice how
important this is when we think back to
what goes on in meditation to and the
entirety of you know thought within the
coach ito to affirm or to deny assert
you could say right I said hey deny to
reject intellectually to say I hold this
to be true I deny this to be true it
also provides us with the capacity to
pursue and to avoid that is in terms of
the modality of goodness and badness so
if I think something is good for me or I
you know I desire it because I am
judging that it's good then I pursue it
I can also choose to reject or avoid it
as well so the will is what does this
the intellect is quite limited in its
power and scope Descartes tells us but
the will in fact has such a great scope
such a great power that he says that in
a certain way if we use the biblical
notion of being created in the image and
likeness of God that's how we're created
so not by the the rational faculty as
such which was an earlier way of
thinking about this it's rather in that
we have an unlimited will our will can
extend to things that don't even exist I
can wish that I had and have a desire
for an ice cream flavor that does not
yet exist but it's so much better than
every ice cream that I've tasted up
until this point all right I imagine
some crazy concoction
like that and my will can extend out to
that and go even further than that and
say I want something even better than
that
right I will by itself doesn't actually
have limits and we might want to think
about what could provide the will with
with limits or as the intellect or the
understanding all sorts of limits
there's all sorts of things that we
don't know all sorts of things that
we'll never know so we've got these two
faculties and they're they're quite
different from each other but they're
working together all the time here's how
we get to the source of our errors how
does error actually occur so Descartes
tells us that the will extends itself to
two things that we don't actually
understand right beyond what it is that
we we do understand and that's what gets
us into trouble we we deny things we
affirm things we pursue things we avoid
things without having an adequate grasp
on the ideas according to Descartes that
code that you know we're working with so
this is a big problem the will he says
will choose the bad in place of the good
or choose the false in place of the true
when it goes beyond what the
understanding can provide it so this
actually suggests to us what it is that
we might do with our wills in order to
avoid falling into error
we should probably restrict ourselves to
limits of our understanding instead of
affirming things that we don't actually
have clear and distinct ideas about or
at least some probability some good
reason to think that that's the case or
perhaps we could derive from previous
principles right we should stop short
and say I'm not going to to will that
I'm not going to affirm it I'm not going
to deny it either because to swing to
the other extreme of denying things that
go beyond the realm of our current
understand
is equally as foolish and equally as bad
a use of the will as to affirm them and
it's very interesting that they Kurt
goes even a little bit further than this
he talks about a certain kind of
indifference right he's you know
thinking about the things that he's
discussed so far in the meditations and
there's this passage where he says I
suppose that I don't know any reason
that would persuade me more to one than
the other of these things from which it
follows that I am entirely indifferent
when it comes to denying or affirming
and then he goes even further or even to
hold myself back from giving any
judgment this is in a certain respect as
thoroughgoing as skepticism as one could
have but it's conceived here as the
proper use proper disciplining proper
limitation of the human mind by the will
itself choosing to do this sort of thing
and so he thinks that if we do this we
can actually avoid falling into errors
in judgment about the existence or
non-existence or the nature or the
goodness or badness or connectedness
cause and effect whatever it is that
we're considering we can avoid falling
into errors about the things that we
think about
you